[Music]
you same way necklace not
the pressure was on during Tuesday's
battle rounds on the voice as Chris blue
and RJ Collins faced off for a spot on
team Alicia and coach Gwen Stefani got a
little hot and bothered Chris you let
yourself completely get absorbed into
the music I don't even know if I was
listening to your voice cuz I was so
mesmerized by your body oh I know how do
we mean it like that
hey what the circuit the node out front
woman was so fixated on Chris she could
barely focus on RJ I was having a hard
time focusing cuz you kept distracting
me what's your problem man what's your
problem
Oh any trouble but it wasn't just Chris
or Jay also had Gwen feeling some type
of way RJ I I did not know you're 18
years old I mean you look at a man you
thank you once again here we go
before Alysha chose Chris as the winner
blake shelton made this hilarious
confession by the way i hope you're not
available to steal because I'll probably
lose my girlfriend will be like
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you